care those girls a lot of them did go on
to date white guys from The Bachelor of
course but it's like I I think if if
you're a certain level of hot they just
don't like yeah they don't care you're
right yeah no you're right yeah if
you're if you are yeah if you're
extremely hot like if you're a hard 10
most guys like it doesn't matter yeah
you'll you'll get guys to date you but
if you're just a little bit more like if
if you're like in the five six seven
range and it really depends upon the
value of the black guy if the black guy
has options then he's gonna be like okay
because we were just we were just uh
talking about this in the living room we
we want to be the first we want to be
that we want to be the first that run up
in white girls and that's just listen
that's an ego thing that's not always
the case yeah no I I do think like I I
do think guys prefer to people black
guys prefer to be the first the first
you better believe it are you like are
you a virgin uh no are you a virgin
virgin you know what I'm saying oh yeah
yes yeah that's done so so what are so
what's your opinion on interracial
dating because my girlfriend is white
and you like you like and a lot of
people think that a lot of people think
you just like black guys no you're six
feet tall like you are a towering figure
yeah and we know that women are not
trying to date men that are shorter than
them and black men it would appear a lot
uh uh we have a higher percentage of
tall guys in our race than white guys so
what's the what's a lot of sense I
didn't know that but Nicholas well yeah
I mean like and I don't know I don't
know what the percentages are but I mean
I mean we live life you live in another
country yeah there are tall white men
and tall black men but it just seems
that they're more tall black guys than
tall white guys so in in dating for me I
like race hasn't really been an issue
right it's been the harder thing to me
is like class if like someone's from a
very like a lower socioeconomic economic
class to like the higher I think that's
more difficult than race really it might
just well as a woman I guess yeah just
in my experience uh wow because I I
think that's harder than race wow my mom
I was actually talking about something
my mom tried to like be careful but I'll
just I'll just say it my mom told me
growing up that like so if you're in
middle class or upper middle class you
can date one up or one down but it's
really hard to skip two and it's funny
because Kevin Samuel was like before
before he passed away like this is
something he told me
um like when I was asking him about my
boyfriend at the time and by the way
just real quick for the record you and
Ali have both been in The Crucible with
Kevin Samuels you guys have experience
yes a lot of people don't know I talked
to him after the show oh dude a lot of
people don't know that I did not know
that yeah and he he basically told me
not to be with the guy I was dating at
the time and he kind of he's like like
you could date and Ivy League like you
could do that and I and um Kevin was
right but it's kind of like because and
it kind of goes back to what my mom said
where I'm like I grew up like upper
middle class because my parents do well
but they it wasn't always that way and
so it's like you can go one up to like
Ivy and then there's like Elite I would
say yeah but it's like it would be hard
for someone and I could go like down to
middle class maybe like lo you know
local middle class but it would be
really hard for me to date someone that
like comes from like the hood because
it's just like the values tend to be
different so personally I'm just saying
personally I I found that like different
social social classes is harder than
race because if you grow up in the same
area like if if someone grew up down the
road for me we kind of grew up around
the same sure to have the same value
yeah yeah yeah I guess uh yeah that does
make sense you got something oh closer
okay uh okay
yeah yeah I'll have to I'll get up and
move it over okay okay cool okay
um
it's interesting to hear that from a
from a woman's uh perspective now from a
man's perspective I think if a man I
think if a man grows up in the you know
upper middle upper middle class upper
social socioeconomic status I think he
doesn't mind dating dating a couple down
as long as the girl is hot enough if she
brings value Etc et cetera it's a family
that will have the problem with that
that's what I was gonna say because even
with my brothers like they've had girls
they've brought home where it's like we
couldn't take you to certain things sure
the way you carry yourself yeah you know
and those were for fun girl you know my
brothers do well with the ladies
recreational use only shout out shout
out Adam
like Chris pogson says shout out 304s
yeah yeah but pogson's a sneak he's a
sneak tip assassin but yeah I think um
it's interesting I don't think I've ever
talked about the socio-economic
implications of dating up or down we
know that women always want to date up
and you should want to date up I have
never I've never said oh well girls only
want to do guys who make money well guys
want to bang girls who are hot it's it's
literally the same thing but the but
again the the economic class situation
it makes it it really does add another
element because as a man I never take
that into consideration ever because I'm
a man as far as I'm concerned it doesn't
matter and dude I've dated Grinch girls
all the way to trailer trash and Devin
she comes from an upper middle class
family so you know we we fit in really
well but I've always told her I told her
we first started dating she was like oh
yeah yeah my parents would love you I
said well of course they would love me
now but would they love me if you were
16 and I were 15. the answer to that
would be no so what does your I mean I'm
sure you're and I'm sure your mom and
dad are cool people what does your
family think about you dating in a
racially have you ever caught any Flack
or heat or maybe got the side eye or
maybe one of your brothers is like hey
bro let me let me let me let me talk to
you let me talk at you no they don't
care okay all right they don't I mean
they've had like I've had I've had a
boyfriend like they didn't like but it
was it was it wasn't anything to do with
like race they were pretty easy like
easy going people so right my parents
have always been like
very much like you can do what you want
to do right and we'll we'll support you
but like
you know don't complain later right
right right right no I got you I got you
now guys you guys are you are listening
to the hashtag how to relationship
podcast this is a special podcast with
our special guest uh just pearly things
AKA Pearl uh you're very very popular uh
you're very very popular in the chat
um so let's let's switch gears here and
talk about your podcast
what what when what was the aha moment
when did you know I think I have
something here because you're at over
460 000 subscribers now what and
congratulations for that Holy Smokes man
you work hard at it uh you deserve all
the success because just like I told
Devin Devin was like how in the world
and not that she doesn't respect that I
said you do what
99.9 of content creators are unable to
do get guests in studio there's a reason
why Joe Rogan has the most successful
podcast in the world and so Myron Gaines
and and uh and uh you know the fresh and
fit podcast it's the same thing so take
me from the beginning when you started
to figure out okay maybe I have
something here
um
so in the beginning I thought London was
cool okay because I I moved from Chicago
to London to play volleyball okay and
what I thought was cool was on my team I
had a girl from Germany a girl from
England a girl from America a girl from
Spain okay and so what I was thinking is
wow I can be in this city and I can talk
to people that have completely different
views on relationships wow and I have
never been in such a as many of you know
I was just banned on Tick Tock and we
are demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible